Hello. This is 6 minute English
from BBC Learning English.
I'm Neil
and I'm Beth.
There's a famous English saying
'a friend in need is a friend indeed'.
And it's true - everyone needs friends
to share life's ups and downs.
Do you have many friends, Neil?
Yes, I have some close friends,
but maybe not as many as I'd like.
That's interesting because often it's women
who have many friends
while men find it harder to maintain
strong friendships,
especially as they get older.
In fact, according
to one recent survey
only twenty seven percent
of British men say they have
at least six close friends.
So, is it true that men find
it difficult to make friends?
We'll be hearing from
Max Dickens, author of a book
on male friendship called Billy No-
Mates and as usual, we'll be learning
some useful new vocabulary as well.
But first, I have a question for you.
We know that close friends are
important not just for having fun,
but for good mental health as well.
So, according to research
by Oxford University's Institute
of cognitive anthropology,
how many close friends
do we need for our mental wellbeing?
Is it a) five b) ten or c) twenty?
I'll say we need
at least five close friends.
OK, Neil, I'll reveal the answer
at the end of the programme.
Now, however many friends you have,
It's a stereotype
that women are better than men
at making and keeping close friends.
Here's Claudia Hammond outlining
the problem for BBC Radio four programme
'All in the mind'.
Now, when times are tough, friends are
often the people who get us through,
who are there to listen,
to reassure, maybe to advise us,
if that's what we want.
So, why do we sometimes find it hard
to make friends or that the friends
we used to have seemed
to have somehow drifted away.
Now, there is an idea that women are much
better at maintaining their friendships
and that men are more likely to hang
out with whoever is around rather
than to nurture those relationships
and we were wondering whether
this was really true or is that
just a stereotype?
Claudia uses the phrase,
'times are tough' to describe
a situation of trouble, unhappiness
or financial difficulty.
Friends help us get through
these difficult periods of life.
The phrasal verb,
'get through' has several meanings,
but here it means managed to live
through an unpleasant period of time.
The problem may be that
your friends have drifted away -
gradually moved further and further
away until your connection
with them has broken and it seems
that's especially true for men.
That's right. When author Max Dickens
was getting married,
he realised he didn't have
any close male friends
he could ask to be his best man -
the person who helps the groom
at a wedding.
This led him to write
the book, Billy No-Mates,
looking at why he
didn't have any close male friends.
Here's Claudia Hammond again,
talking with Max for BBC Radio
four programme,'All in the mind'.
Max, it's interesting
that you kind of went public on this
if you like. You know, your book
is even called 'Billy
No-Mates', the very thing, you know,
that a lot of us would dread being.
It can't have been easy to decide
to say this publicly in a way.
No, it's a real double-edged
sword being the face
of a book called 'Billy No-mates',
I've got to say.
But I think, so, loneliness
doesn't look like me.
I'm in my early to mid-thirties.
I'm pretty outgoing.
I'm quick to buy my round.
It shouldn't look like me
but, increasingly, it does. So, loneliness,
isn't just the elderly anymore,
it's younger people.
Max called his book, 'Billy No-Mates' -
slang for a person with no friends.
It's a memorable book title,
but Max says being the public face
of a book called
'Billy No-Mates' is a double edged sword.
Something with unfavourable as well
as favourable consequences.
In fact, Max doesn't look
like someone with no friends.
He's young, generous and outgoing -
an adjective describing someone who's
friendly and enjoys meeting people.
But, increasingly loneliness
is affecting younger men,
thanks partly to social media,
which can make it seem
as though everyone is having a great
time with their mates except you.
Max thinks the answer is getting out
and meeting people in third spaces.
Places like sports clubs or reading
groups which are separate from either
home or work.
All of which helps get closer
to the magical number of friends
needed for good mental health.
I think it's time you revealed
the answer to your question, Beth.
Yes, I asked how
many close friends.
We need for our mental wellbeing.
You said it was five,
which was the correct answer.
According to Oxford University's
Professor Robin Dunbar,
we need a core,
circle of five close friends,
plus a wider support network
of about ten,
making a total number of fifteen
friends for good mental health.
OK, let's recap the vocabulary
from the programme,
starting with the phrase.
'Times are tough', which describes
periods of trouble or difficulty in life
If you get through something,
you managed to live through
a difficult situation.
To 'drift away' means to gradually move
further apart from someone until your
relationship with them eventually ends.
'Billy No-Mates' is slang
for someone who has no friends.
A 'double-edged sword'
describes something
with unfavourable as well
as favourable consequences.
And finally, the adjective 'outgoing'
describes someone who is very friendly
and enjoys talking to people
Once again, our six minutes are up.
Good bye for now. Bye.